zahoud travail partout au québec des
milliers de citoyens anxieux sont
dirigés chaque jour vers des centres de
dépistage de lakovic 19 mai la tente
peut parfois être longue avant d'obtenir
un rendez-vous devenu denaisis de 16,7
j'ai fait un premier appel au centre
vide 2 à 4 jours mais m'ont jamais
appelé pour répondre à la demande à
partir de lundi matin un nouveau centre
de dépistage sans rendez vous ouvrira
ses portes dans le quartier des
spectacles de montréal
les patients devront rencontrer certains
critères pour y avoir accès soit
présenté des symptômes comme la fièvre
la toux ou des difficultés respiratoires
ils devront aussi soit être revenu de
voyage à l'étranger dans les 14 derniers
jours avoir été en contact étroit avec
quelqu'un qui rêve d'une voyage durant
cette même période
ou avoir été en contact avec une
personne porteuse du virus
pour limiter les risques de transmission
la nouvelle clinique sera en partie
extérieure et les gens auront accès à un
service à l'auto
le premier ministre du québec promet que
l'amélioration de la détection de la
maladie se fera sentir un peu partout
dans la province
on a depuis hier accélérer le nombre de
tests
donc c'est normal que le nombre de corps
augmente même la plus grosse
augmentation s'attend ce qui arrive
demain à l'échelle du pays le
gouvernement fédéral tente aussi de
déployer une technologie qui permettrait
de faciliter le dépistage 20 tandis que
la capacité de dépister la maladie
augmente qu'avec 19 continue de se
répandre québec affirme que les critères
pour tester la population seront sans
doute élargie revu constamment pour
réfléter l'éclosion du virus
ici pierre le gagnant radio canada
montréal